dix ans après la chute du mur on dresse
aussi en ce début de semaine le bilan de
la réunification de l'est et de l'ouest
l'est allemand avec sa protection
sociale l'ouest avec sa croissance
économique
olivier werner & young and move qui ont
croisé deux itinéraires celui d'une
femme la perdante victimes de cette
réunification est celui d'un homme le
gagnant qui en a profité
deux portraits pour bien comprendre les
bienfaits comme les échecs de ces
dernières années un vrai bureau de
patron pour cet ancien communiste pur et
dur en l'espace de dix ans hans-jürgen
l2 avoue avoir évolué comme 600 ans
s'étaient écoulés
la vie était belle pour diana sautner
avant la chute du mur un mari un enfant
un bon salaire d'ingénieurs mais
aujourd'hui elle croule sous les dettes
et doit rendre des comptes
le triomphe du petit fabricant de
médicaments est-allemand devenu
capitaliste le stress la déprime la
déchéance la menace de se retrouver à la
rue pour diane a perdu devant cet
inspecteur des impôts qui réclame son dû
un matériel italien ultra moderne avant
89 ils étaient 2000 attaché à la
production il n'en reste que 240
personnes seulement s'occuper du
marketing
ils sont plus de mille aujourd'hui un
changement de structure avec à la clé 12
son licenciement après la chute du mur
comme nora voulez vous que je reste ou
que je ne reste pas c'est la question
qui a été posée aux employés d'un
référendum en 90 j'ai été surpris par le
résultat ils ont dit oui à 91% au moment
de la privatisation j'ai pris des
décisions importantes licencier une
partie du personnel
et là ce fut un problème énorme diana
regrette la disparition de la rda
elle a des arguments je suis au chômage
je n'ai plus ma propre maison je dois
aussi me c'est cet appartement
je n'ai plus d'argent mais ce que
j'aimerais bien revoir le mur avec trois
mètres d'hauteur remplissent le bâtiment
d'aujourd'hui fait face à celui d'hier
et arbore fièrement son nouveau logo
germano italien vision il imagine
dans le berlin est des années 80 diana
vit seule avec son fils il est né il ya
tout juste dix ans au moment de la chute
du mur
elles rêvent simplement de pouvoir lui
offrir un ordinateur
s'il refait surface